the most ridiculous thing about the Hulk
is his pants
yeah he never loses his pants he's so
much bigger than Bruce Banner Bruce
Banner is like a little unassuming
scientist who's built like Ben Shapiro
and then all of a sudden he turns into
that guy and the pants somehow still fit
how the [__] how the [__] do you not see
that giant green dick
those pants would pop off just the same
way a shirt would right this is
ridiculous somebody needs to do a new
version of the Hulk with the giant green
dick like uh the like like Dr Manhattan
Primal Hulk and he's built the Hulk same
thing you can see his dick we can't see
the Hulk stick
yeah the idea that his shirt explodes
but it's pants like stay fine and you
can move around on them no problem what
the [__] are you selling about they
didn't they didn't know the way around
that one like how do we it is the
dumbest [__] thing of all time I mean
even if he's wearing yoga pants those
[__] shits Are Gonna Fly apart it's
gonna rip it's gonna rip that's crazy
look how big he is yeah he's five times
the size of the regular [__]
that he is before he blows up it's so
dumb it's the dumbest thing if we're so
afraid of that giant green dick
that is crazy people will say ridiculous
[__] like well how could he turn into
some such a big thing there's not enough
molecules in his body to expand to that
extent where is he getting the actual
physical tools to get bigger yeah yeah
what about his pants
yeah do his pants have the same thing he
got it doesn't make sense that something
could just get big though how could he
get big there's no food there's no where
does this how do the cells grow is he
just drinking water and growing like a
plant like what are you doing yeah how
are you getting bigger how do you get
bigger like you have there's a mass
where's the mass come from it how does
it go back to normal
it's so dumb with the pants are the
dumbest yeah the pants the dumbest thing
the whole thing meanwhile it's my
favorite superhero